what's up guys I'm Tamara and today I'm
here at BuzzFeed promoting my new season
of my show MTV nofilter tanomo Joe and
I'm so excited to tell you that I'm
gonna be reading thirst tweets today one
time I dated the guy and went with him
to do this and had to watch him read
other thirsty tweets from other people
and I was so jealous Oh someone's at an
emotional is literally the most
beautiful human ever goodbye
have you seen literally any
jenner/kardashian sweetie
there's so many more beautiful people
but thank you for thinking at Santa mojo
can you lick my forehead I get questions
like this at my meet and greets all the
time I feel like I've been asked to lick
kiss every body part ever so no I can't
Tanna mojo invented slim fit thank you
but I think they just invented face tune
hey by Anna Moses boobs I to be
unstoppable lmao I am they helped so
thank you
repeat after me it's an emotional makes
me horny ten emotional experience an
emotion makes me horny gentle it makes
my own example it makes me continue that
motion makes her horny I love that for
you thank you san emotion was the best
boobs that's it that's the tweet I
really do see so many tweets about my
boobs over anything else even my
personality wow I hope that changes when
I like released a book or something I
want to have a threesome with Tana mojo
but it's just her a blunt and it's
probably my ideal threesome I'm not
gonna lie party games animals are
specifically catered her new video to my
fetishes but watching her lick and ice
and whisper do you want me to murder you
and then smoke a blunt was too much for
me hey I think we have similar fetishes
so and B I don't remember doing this at
all which is also just really
embarrassing I kind of lick knives often
I smoke blunts very often so at least
three times a week me and my boyfriend
talked about wanting to have a threesome
sanitizer do I look like a third to you
like sending love babe but no it would
pay any amount of money for Tanner Moser
just spit in my face and call me an ugly
it was evening honor a every means
realize whoever is this tweet and be
that's how it sex it was like so crazy
I would love a bucket like this but just
of my tweets about david dobrik tena
Mozart gonna choke me and run me over
and I'd say thank you and sorry for the
desk in the car dude this is what I mean
when I say that my fans are just as
crazy as me I say this about other
people like there are lots of other
people that could literally hit me with
a car net apologize so don't that no
offence but I want that emotion to sit
on my face until i suffocate she doesn't
see me and bigotry what I hope she
doesn't see this is really funny but
also I saw it if I ever met Tina Moshe I
would let her roar them Academy what is
warming I feel like I know most things
I'll have to urban dictionary whatever
it is I probably wouldn't do don't can't
shame me but I would let Tana mojo pipes
so hard no king shaming here Popoff
Queen I want an emotional tomorrow my
[ __ ] pussy's such a good word my best
friend Trevor says that all the time
which you can watch on my MTV no filter
show like what orifice what I use to
murder your bookie I need an emotional
whip me around by my neck and spits out
my esophagus while singing Hafner enjoy
turning inside out and turn into a
strawberry Molly water smoothie why do I
feel like this is just everything
Millennials say into like a generalized
tweet and like Molly water they have go
to church the final one which I'm
terrified of do you give tweets like
these to like the Jonas Brothers when
they come in
everyone off cameras like Jordan you
want to come read this one what have my
manager read this to me Jordan come on
in Wow it is extremely specific animal
Joel with it these breathtaking
it would be so flesh sure to axe
everyone be once in a while I wax all
the time foreskin when you Sookie I got
it just gets so much worse and that's
saying so much for me I say these words
like super on the daily in bed but I'm
sorry sweetie that's not happening I
hate to let you down Blake don't have a
dick thanks for having me BuzzFeed
[Music]